you have a minute for god,
Lord?
Do not punish me in your anger
and do not chastise me in your Grimm.
Have mercy on Me,
Lord,
I'm languishing.
heal me, Lord,
for my limbs are decaying,
my soul is deeply disturbed.
but you, Lord,
how long do you continue to hem?
Lord turn to Me and save me in your favor.
Bring Me Help,
because with the dead no one thinks about you anymore.
who will still prize you in the underworld?
i am exhausted from drinking.
every night streams of tears wet My bed.
I flood My camp with tears.
My eye is clouded with sorrow.
I have aged because of all my opponents.
soft back from Me,
all you wicked ones,
for the Lord has heard My loud weeping.
the Lord has heard My supplication,
the Lord accepts My prayer.
All my enemies are in disgrace and disturbance.
they must give way
and perish.